Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here
and today I want to talk about
listening comprehension, how to
improve our listening comprehension,
uh, based on my experience.
Uh, remember that that listening
comprehension, at least for me
is, is the fundamental goal,
the fundamental activity.
You wanna understand
what people are saying.
If you can understand movies, if you
can understand podcasts, if you can
understand, you know, conversations,
the other end of the conversation, you
can eventually get to where you can
hold up your end of the conversation.
Uh, I spend up most of my time listening.
Listening comprehension is, is
where the action is in my opinion.
Of course.
I mentioned reading as a way to increase
your vocabulary so that later on
when you hear these words, you might
have a chance to understand them.
But listening comprehension is
where I spend most of my time.
But before I get into more detail,
I want to tell you two stories.
So first of all, Uh, the
first takes place in St.
Petersburg, Russia.
I had been studying Russian for
four years, I guess, off and on.
I listened to audio
books, Russian literature.
I listened to political
discussions from a radio station.
I understood a lot of
Russian, and I'm in St.
Petersburg.
I want to buy a train ticket to go to
Vyborg, which is just north of, of St.
Petersburg on the electric train.
And so I'm waiting in line and, uh,
finally it's my turn to tell the
lady there behind the counter what
I wanted and, uh, a certain amount
of trepidation here, you know, using
the language in not to listen to
political discussion, but to use it in
a very practical, specific situation.
And I said, I would like to
buy a ticket to go to Vyborg.
And she comes back at me with
something and I didn't understand
what she said and I had to repeat
and, and ask her to repeat.
And finally, whatever she
said, I can't remember.
Uh, I got the picture and I
paid her and I got my ticket.
So that's one situation.
Uh, another situation I was
talking to, we have a Mexican
gardener here in Palm Springs.
And, uh, we were talking about
different things and all of a
sudden he said, uh, I said, what?
"Pow", "pow", what's "pow"?
And finally, I figured out it was pago.
It had to do with his payment.
Somehow his bank transfers
weren't going through.
What's the significance of
these two little stories?
I have found time and time again
that in order to understand a part.
Um, context, you kind of have
to have experienced it before.
So you have to be able to
anticipate what is coming at you.
And if you have not had that
particular situation before,
it will be more difficult.
So the second time, or the third
time that I go to buy a train ticket
in Russia, it'll be easier for me
'cause I've already experienced it.
I can anticipate what the
person's going to say.
Uh, similarly with, with this Mexican
gardener, if I knew kind of roughly the
context of what he was talking about,
I might have been able to connect
the fact that Pago to him was almost
"pow", or at least I heard it as "pow".
And this is important because
there's so many different accents,
even within a particular accent.
People have different ways
of pronouncing things.
It's very important to
therefore be able to anticipate.
And what that means is when you don't
understand, don't criticize yourself.
Don't blame yourself.
The fact that you're in a situation
where you don't understand is a good
thing because you have now time to
think about that, and so next time
around you probably will do better.
I mean, you can do things just by
dent of doing a lot of listening.
You are exposing yourself to
more different situations.
Even if you're, you know, watching a
series on Netflix, uh, you're sort of
involved now in a, in an environment.
It might be a family, it might be,
gosh knows whatever is happening
and as you spend more and more time
in that situation, you're gradually
going to understand more because
you're becoming familiar with, with
what people say to each other within
that particular context that you
have been sort of catapulted into.
So I, I only wanna make this point because
I, I think people sometimes get very
upset if, if they feel they have a good
level of comprehension and then they're
put in a very specific situation and they
have trouble understanding what is said.
No harm done.
You ask the person to repeat as
I did with a Mexican gardener or
with a, I shouldn't say Mexican.
He's a, he's an American, but he doesn't
speak English here in Palm Springs.
Uh, or with the, uh, the lady
selling the train ticket in St.
Petersburg, I just ask again.
And, uh, so, you know, my advice,
uh, uh, in terms of listening
comprehension is, you know, expose
yourself to as many different accents.
As many different situations, as
many different contexts as possible.
And recognize that there will always
be situations where even some of the
most basic bits of vocabulary will
pass you by things that you think
you should be able to understand.
You won't understand them.
And that's just part of improving
your listening comprehension.
And uh, and that's why I should say
by the way, that exposing yourself
to, you know, speaking situations,
not being afraid to make mistakes,
not being afraid to not understand.
Having one situation where you didn't
understand and you go back in there again.
And the third time you will
understand that particular context.
And there are so many other contexts that
you need to, you know, expose yourself to.
Uh, so a big part of language, you know,
in progressing in our languages is having
a sense of confidence, and that means
not becoming overly concerned about
situations where you didn't understand.
Just keep going.
So I have talked before about listening
comprehension, and I'll leave you with
a couple of videos on the subject.
I hope this is helpful.
Bye for now.